اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
واشنطن تبدا تدريب الطيارين الاوكران على
مقاتلات اف 16 الاسبوع المقبل وتتعهد
بمواصله التزويد
عمران العمراني
وفلوريدا ينضم للسباق الى البيت الابيض
بفعاليه على تويتر شابتها الفوضى مع سخريه
من جانب ترامب
والاحزاب الكرديه تؤكد دعمها في جوله
الاعاده بانتخابات تركيا وتتعهد التصويت
ضد اردوغان
فيضانات في الجزائر تسبب خسائر ماديه
وغلقا للطرقات وسيولا في العاصمه
اهلا بكم قبل ان ندخل في تفاصيل نشره
الخامسه نتوقف ما اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي
منذ قليل اسقاط مسيره صغيره اجتازت الحدود
من لبنان فقد قال الجيش الاسرائيلي في
بيان الله ان المسيره تم اسقاطها بعد
تعقبها وانه سيواصل العمل من اجل التصدي
الانتهاك سياده اسرائيل حسب ما جاء في
البيع
ينضم الي عبر الهاتف من القدس لمزيد من
المتابعه مدير مكتب العربيه في فلسطين
زياد حلب بزياده اهلا وسهلا بك اي تفاصيل
اضافيه حول ملابسات هذه الحادثه زياده
قبل نحو ساعتين من الان تقريبا جرى تعقب
واسقاط هذه المسيره الصغيره مسيره تستخدم
للتصوير هذه ليست المره الاولى هذا حدث
مرات عده هذا النوع بالذات من المسيرات
الذي يستخدم
للتصوير
الجيش الاسرائيلي طبعا هو مستنفر تماما في
على الحدود الشماليه هناك كما تعرف توتر
في الفتره الاخيره على هذه الحدود بشقيها
اللبناني والسوري اسرائيل لم توجه اتهاما
مباشره لحزب الله ولكن المصادر في اسرائيل
تؤكد ان هذه المسيره قد تكون تابعه لحزب
الله وتمت من يربط ذلك طبعا بمناسبه
الذكرى الثالثه والعشرين
للانسحاب الاسرائيلي من جنوب لبنان زياد
لو عطفنا ما جرى اليوم مع ما جرى بالامس
في اجواء الجولان وتصدي دفاعات جويه سوريه
لمسيره اسرائيليه ماذا يمكن ان نقول
يمكن ان نقول بان ثمه تحرك النشطا عسكريا
وامنيا على الجبل الشماليه بشقيها
اللبناني والسوري فعلا جرى اطلاق نار على
مسيره اسرائيليه الجيش الاسرائيلي رد
باطلاق نيران رشاشه اتجاه مواقع للجيش
السوري في الجنوبي سوريا في منطقه
القنيطره تحديدا هذا يدلل على وجود التوتر
على هذه
جبهه باسرائيل هناك تحذيرات متواتره في
الايام الاخيره لجهه ان يكون هناك امكان
ان يقوم حزب الله او جهه اخرى
باختبار هذه الجبهه عسكريا وامنيا في
الفتره المقبله ورئيس الاركان الاسرائيلي
حذر فقط قبل يومين من هذا الموضوع وقال
يعني الاشاره في اسرائيل كانت الى ان
العمليه الاخيره التي كانت على حدود لبنان
عمليه مجدو كما سميت تسلل مقاتل
وفجر عبوه في سياره قبل ان يقتله يقتله
الاسرائيليون عمليا اسرائيل لم ترد على
هذه العمليه وهناك يعني
رايي في اسرائيل يقول بان حزب الله قد
يكرر هذه الاختبارات للجده قريبا عبر
الهاتف من القدس مدير مكتب العربيه في
فلسطين زياد حلبي دائما شكرا لك زياده على
كل هذه المتابعه
الى الشان الاوكرانيه الان فقد قال وزير
الدفاع الامريكي ان تدريب الطيارين
الاوكران على طائرات سيبدا الاسبوع المقبل
وخلال كلمه له في اجتماع لمجموعه الاتصال
الدفاعيه الخاصه باوكرانيا اكد اوستن انه
سيتم امداد اوكرانيا بكافه الذخائر
الضروريه لمساعدتها في الهجوم المضاد
مجموعه العمل المشتركه تتاكد ان الجنود
الاوكرانيين يتلقون التدريبات اللازمه
نواصل العمل على تدريب جماعي للوحدات
الاوكرانيه في وقت سابق من هذا الشهر وصلت
31 دبابه من طراز ابرز الى المانيا وفي
الاسبوع الماضي اعلن الرئيس بايدن ان
الولايات المتحده والحلفاء ملتزمون بتدريب
الطيارين الاوكرانيين على الطائرات من
الجيل الرابع بما في ذلك مقاتله اف 16 هذه
التدريبات ستبدا الاسبوع المقبل وذلك من
شانه ان يعزز قدرات القوات الجويه
الاوكرانيه على المدى الطويل
على صعيد اخر اعتبر الناطق باسم لكريملم
ديمتري تصريحات من ان بوتين هو الهدف رقم
واحد بانها ارهابيه مشيرا الى ان العمليه
العسكريه الخاصه اكثر من مبرره وضروريه
ومؤكده ايضا على ضروره اكمالها لتحقيق
الاهداف المحدده
في غضون ذلك كشفت اجهزه مخابرات امريكيه
ان وحده اوكرانيه خاصه تابعه للجيش او
المخابرات الاوكرانيه قد تكون دبرت الهجوم
بطائرات مسيره الذي استهدف الكرملين مؤخرا
وذكر تقرير لصحيفه يورك تايمز ان التقييم
الامريكي استند الى اتصالات روسيه
واوكرانيه جرى رصدها مضيفا ان الولايات
المتحده رصدت محادثات اوكرانيه عبر فيها
مسؤولون عن اعتقادهم ان بلدهم مسؤول عن
هذا الهجوم الصحيفه اشارت ايضا الى ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين لا يعتقدون ان
الرئيس الاوكراني يوقع على جميع العمليات
السريه
الرئاسه الروسيه اعلنت انها كانت تعلم منذ
البدايه ان اوكرانيا هي وراء الهجوم
بطائره مسيره على مبنى
من جهه نفى مساعد الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائيل بودولاك التقرير الامريكي مؤكدا
ان لا صله الكييف بالهجوم الذي وصفه بغير
المؤثر وان روسيا تسعى لاثاره مخاوف الغرب
للحد من تسليم الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا
بموازاه ذلك اعلن جهاز الامن الروسي انه
تمكن من احباط عمليه تخريبيه قال انها
دبرت من خلال التعاون بين المخابرات
الاوكرانيه
ومواطني ومواطنين روسيين وكانت تستهدف نحو
30 خط كهرباء لمحطات الطاقه النوويه في
مقاطاعتي
قبل عيد النصر
قائد مجموعه فيلق المتطوعين الروس
المناوبه لروسيا والتي تبنت الهجوم
الاخيره على الاراضي الروسيه كان تعهد
بمزيد من الغارات عبر الحدود داخل روسيا
وحذر دينيس كابوستين من تزايد وجود عناصره
داخل روسيا ما دفع وزير الدفاع الروسي
بالرد عليه متعهدا برد قاس على اي توغلات
مستقبليه
الحكومه الروسيه من جهتها اعلنت عن تصفيه
اكثر من 70 شخصا من هؤلاء المتمردين
اتهمتهم بمحاوله تفجير خطوط الكهرباء
الروسيه بالتعاون مع الاستخبارات
الاوكرانيه كيف في المقابل نفت رسميا
تورطها في ذلك الهجوم الذي انطلق من داخل
اوكرانيا
هذا وتقول روسيا ان من ان من عبر حدودها
ومقاتلون اوكرانيون ينتمون الى مجموعتين
شبه عسكريتين روسيتين مناهضتين للكرملين
المجموعتان تعلنان دائما انهما تريدان
تفكيك نظام الرئيس الروسي وهما جزء من
فيلق دوري يشارك في الدفاع عن اراضي
اوكرانيا
فيلقوا المتطوعين الروس برز في مارس من
عام 20 23 حيث شارك في غاره عبر الحدود في
منطقه بريانيسك الروسيه
واعلن وقتها مشاركه خمسه واربعين شخصا من
الفيلق في تلك الغارات على كل لمزيد من
المتابع ينضم الي منذسك مراسل العربيه
رائد اهلا وسهلا
بك المشهد الميداني رائد في ضوء تصريحات
لبعض المسؤولين العسكريين الاوكران من ان
الهجوم المضاد قد بدا هل لهذا الكلام ما
يؤكده ام مجرد كلام رائد
مساء الخير طالب يعني تطور مضطرد في
العمليات العسكريه هنا في مناطق النزاع في
اوكرانيا لا يمكن فك ارتباطه عن التطورات
في موسكو وتصريحات
الدفاع الروسيه والتطور الاقليمي بشكل
كامل بالفعل يعني وصول وزير الدفاع الروسي
الى العاصمه البيلاروسيه وتوقيع اتفاقيات
لنشر اسلحه
نوويه تكتيكيه غير استراتيجيه على المناطق
على الحدود الغربيه من بيلاروسيا هذا تطور
كبير في الازمه مرتبط بالازمه الاوكرانيه
طبعا يعني يتحدث ايضا يعني المتحدث الرسمي
باسم الكريم
يقول بان التطورات الاقليميه والتحديات
الكبيره التي تواجهها روسيا لابد من
مواجهتها بشكل مناسب ذلك في تصري عن
التصعيد الحاصل ما بين الغرب او حلف شمال
الاطلسي الناتو وروسيا بشكل عام يقول بان
دخول دول قريبه من روسيا الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي ونشر مزيد من الاسلحه
الاستراتيجيه والدرع الصاروخيه كما وصى
بالقرب من موسكو هذا يعني يعني يهدد امن
روسيا القومي وكل ذلك مرتبط بالتهديدات
التي تحصل في مناطق الازمه هنا حيث دخول
القوات الاوكرانيه على شكل افراد او
مجموعات كما وصفتها موسكو ارهابيه كما
اسلفت طالب فيل هذا الفيلق القومي كما
وصفته موسكو دخول الى العمق الروسي
واستهداف بطرق ارهابيه كما تقول موسكو
منشات حيويه
كالمنشات النوويه والبارزه يوم امس وشبه
جزيره القرم تقول يقول بشكل مختصر بان
العمليه العسكريه باتت اكثر ضروره اكمالها
وتحقيق اهدافها من السابق اذا الاحداث
مرتبطه ما بين التطور الاقليمي والتطور
الميداني على الارض حيث اليوم انسحبت قوات
فاجنر بعد اكمال سيطرتها على مدينه باقمت
متنفذه
وظهر بتصريحات جديده اليوم نخرج ونكمل
انسحابنا حتى نهايه هذا الشهر ونسلم الجيش
الروسي المناطق والمواقع التي سيطرنا
عليها في مدينه باكموت ذات الوقت الذي
تقول فيه المصادر العسكريه ان الجيش
الروسي ما زال يقاوم على اطراف مدينه
باقمت من الناحيه الغربيه والشماليه
ويتوسع ويصل الى بلدات اخرى الحديث عن
بلده بيليغوروفكا في المحور الشمالي دخل
نصفها الجيش الروسي وهناك معارك ضاريه ان
كان في هذا المحور او في المحور الجنوبيه
يوم امس تحدثنا عن تن ظيف المنطقه
الجنوبيه كامله تفضل رائد شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المتابعه دائما يعني انت تتابع
الامور عن كتب اكثر منا من دونسك مراسل
العربي رائد رغبه شكرا جزيلا لك
الى موسكو لمزيد من التحليل الان ينضم الي
المحلل السياسي
اهلا وسهلا بك اعلان وزير الدفاع الروسي
سرقه عن البدء بنشر اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه
في بيلاروس هل هو مجرد مناوره سياسيه
للضغط على الغرب ام لا الامور ذاهبه
باتجاه خيار نووي ولو تكتيكي غير
استراتيجي ما رايه
انا اعتقد ان هناك محاولات ايضا بما في
ذلك لحمايه بيلاروسيا لتدخل الاجنبي ليس
في عام 2020 كان هناك مظاهرات واسعه في
بيلاروسيا ومحاولات لاسقاط السلطات
المحليه فلذلك طبعا وجود الاسلحه النوويه
تكتيكيه الروسيه في هذه الدوله ستكون او
سيكون النوع من الدمام بالنسبه لي صوت
التقاربه الروسيه البيلاروسي مستمر فيما
يخص الدوله الموحده فلذلك انا اعتقد ان هي
طبعا النوع من المقدمه النوع من الخطوات
التي يعني بصراحه ترسم الخطوط الحمراء
بنسبه الدول الغربيه بسبب ان بعد يعني زرع
الازمه في اوكرانيا فقد تكون هناك محاولات
لنفس الخطوات الخطوات المشابهه في
بيلاروسيا خاصه قلت سابقا كان هناك
المحاولات لاسقاط نظام
رئيس
في موضوع متصل السلطات
المخاب
رات دبرت الهجوم المزيف حسب تعبيرها على
الكرملين من اجل الضغط على الغرب لوقف
امداد اكياس بالاسلحه اليوم هنالك تقارير
لاجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه تقول ان
المخابرات الاوكرانيه قد تكون وراء هذا
الهجوم على
ما الذي يستشف برايك من اعتراف المخابرات
الامريكيه بذلك يعني هل مجرد توزيع ادوار
ام على ما يبدو نحن النار ازدياد الضغوطات
على سلطات الاوكرانيه بسبب هذه المقالات
حاليا في وصله للعلامه الامريكيه كذلك بعض
الاخبار في نفس الوصل للاعلام الامريكيه
والغربيه بشكل عام حول عدد الضحايا في
صفوف الجيش الاوكراني
الضخمه عدد ضخمه وكبير جدا فلذلك على ما
يبدو وفقا لبعض الشعيرات امريكا تحاول ان
تضغط على سلطات في كيف لكي تبدا تلك
السلطات ما يصاب بالهجوم المضاد ولكن طبعا
الايض يشوك في في مصلحه شان هذا الهجوم
بسبب ان في حال فاشل هذا الهجوم ونحن نعلم
ان روسيا قد قامت الخطوط الدفاعيه عميقه
وكذلك تسيطر على الاجواء
في اوكرانيا في فشل هذا الهجوم فبتفاعل
الحل هذا سؤالي
انا يعني كان هل كشف اجهزه المخابرات
الامريكيه عن هذه المعلومات الان يشير الى
ان واشنطن غير موافقه ابدا على استخدام
التقنيات العسكريه الامريكيه في ضرب العمق
الروسي ام لا لا يمكن قول ذلك
ميه بالميه ميه بالميه فلذلك السلطات
الفكيف تدرك ذلك تماما فهذا هو السبب لما
تحاول ان تستعرض او تبتعد السلطات في كيف
عن هجوم على محافظه
ولكن طبعا نحن ندرك تماما وراينا كان هناك
المدرات الغربيه في صفوف هذه المجموعه
التي تدخلت
الاراده الروسيه فتابع الحل امريكا تنظر
الى ذلك يعني طبعا على ما يبدو هي قالقه
وغير راضيه مما يحصل في صفوف السقوطات
الاوكرانيه اضافه لما قلته بخصوصا
المضاد فعلى ما يبدو يعني
رويدا نتواصل الى مرحله الحاسمه لهذه
الازمه اذا بدا هذا الهجوم المضارع
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من موسكو المحلل
السياسي شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
في مناطق المعارك شرقه وجنوب اوكرانيا
تنتشر ساحات التدريب المقاتلين الروس
ويخصص الجيش الروسي ارضيات قريبه من
المعركه ليتاقلم المقاتلون الجدد مع واقع
الحرب والمواجهه ضد الجيش الاوكراني وبشكل
افتراضي
هذا المكان هو لتمرين المستجدين الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق ان كان من الدبابات او
من حتى الاسلحه المتوسطه او الاسلحه
الخفيفه هذه دبابه تمرن عليها الجنود
الروس على الاطلاق واصابه الاهداف في هذه
المواقع المنتشره في مناطق مختلفه ان كان
في باخموت وان كان في او مارنكا في هذه
المقاطعه وهذا الاقليم بالفعل هنا عمليات
التدريب تجريب من حولي كما نرى عدد من
الدبابات
والرماء الذين يحاولون التدريب اكثر على
اصابه الاهداف لمصلحه الجيش الروسي في هذا
المكان يتمرن المستجدون من الجيش الروسي
ان كان بعد التعبئه الجزئيه او حتى من
المتطوعين او من تعاقدوا مع الجيش الروسي
هذه القذائف التي تطلق من الاليات
العسكريه الثقيله هنا تملا المكان خلفي
هناك دبابات وايضا في هذه الناحيه دبابات
تتمرن على اطلاق النار كما اننا نشاهد على
الارض هذه قطع ايضا من القذائف هذه كلها
هذه قطع للتدريب يعني الجنود يتدربون على
الاطلاق واصابه الاهداف في ذلك المحور
البعيد هناك اهداف يجب اصابتها من قبل
المتمرنين والمتدربين اما في هذه الناحيه
فنرى
هنا المتدربين على الاطلاق من الاسلحه
الوسطى وليست الخفيفه ايضا يتمرنون على
اصابه الاهداف في هذا الموقع التدريبي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث رائد الاغبر
وبعيدا عن المعارك الميدانيه اعنت
الخارجيه الروسيه ترضى خمسه دبلوماسيين
سويديين في رد على اجراء مماثل من
ستوكهولم وقالت الخارجيه الروسيه في بيان
لها ان السويد قامت بخطوات عدائيه صريحه
وان العلاقات معها وصلت لمستوى متدني جدا
مشيره الى ان القرار يشمل اغلاق مقر
القنصليه السويديه في سان بيترسبرج
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
فرنسا تدين اطلاق ايران صاروخا بالستيا
بعيدا
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه واجه راندي سانتوس حاكم ولايه
فلوريدا الامريكيه وجه بدايه فوضويه مع
دخول السباق الى البيت الابيض اذ تعرض
موقع تويتر لاعطال خلال فعاليه لاعلان
ترشحه على الانترنت استضافها مالك المنصه
ايلون ماسك
هذا وانقطع الصوت لفترات طويله خلال بث
تويتر المقابله التي استمرت ساعه كما لم
يتمكن الالاف من المستخدمين من الانضمام
لمتابعتها او اجبروا على الخروج
رده فعل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن حاكم
ولايه فلوريدا راندي سانتوس بانه رشح نفسه
رسميا للرئاسه الامريكيه كانت بثلاث كلمات
هذا الرابط يعمل
نشره تغريده لمتابعيه مستخدما هذه الكلمات
مرفقه برابط مخصص لجمع التبرعات من اجل
حمله اعاده ترشحه للرئاسه برفقه نائبته
كما لا
اما ترامب المنافس الجمهوري الابرز امام
ديسنتوس فقد نشر مقطع فيديو عدد فيه
انجازاته وقلل من شان وعود حاكم فلوريدا
الانتخاب
دواشن
تنظيم اميركا
هو حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوري وهو المنافس
الرئيسي لدونالد ترامب يصنف ديسنتوس او
يصنف ديسانتس نفسه على انه محافظ على غرار
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب لكن من دون
اخطائه
وتتمثل فكره ديسانس للترشح في ان لديه
سجلا حافلا من الانجازات المتعلقه بالقيم
المحافظه والتي حققها خلال مسيرته
السياسيه
فقد سند سانتوس قوانين محافظه رفيعه
المستوى لتسهيل امتلاك السلاح وتقييد
تعليم الهويه الجنسيه في المدارس وتشديد
قواعد التصويت في الانتخابات والحد من
عمليات الاجهاض
واشار ديسانتوس ايضا الى استعداده لمواجهه
الشركات الكبرى التي يرى انها تقدم اجنده
ليبراليه في حال كسب الانتخابات
كما يطرح قضيه انه يفوز دائما ولم يهزم في
سباقات الكونجرس او لمنصب حاكم فلوريدا
لمزيد من المتابعات حول هذا الموضوع معي
من واشنطن مراسله العربيه اهلا وسهلا
في مقابله ديسانتس ناديه واعلان ترشحه ولو
عبر منصه تويتر شكلا ومضمونا برغم كل
المشاكل التي اعتورت هذه المقابله المشاكل
التقنيه عبر تويتر
اهلا بك الطالب اولا مشكله ديسنتوس ليس
فقط هي مشاكل تقنيه وبان هذا الرابط يعمل
او لا يعمل مشكلته حسب كل المتابعين منذ
الامس وحتى الان هو ان هذا الفيديو كان
مسموع فقط وليس مرئيا يعني المرشح الرئاسي
يجب ان يطرح وجوده بقوه على منصه اولا لا
يشاركه احد اختار ان يشاركه فيها طبعا
ايلون ماسك وهو يتمتع بالنرجسيه يريد ان
يكون الرجل رقم واحد
ويتقاسموا هذه المنصه عدا انه لم يكن
موجود بشكل يعني مرئي وبالتالي عندما
نتوقع من من مرشح للرئاسه يريد ان ينافس
وان يطيح بالرئيس ترامب سواء كان جمهوري
او حتى الرئيس بايدن يجب ان يتوجه
برساله متلفزه للشعب الامريكي للناخبين
ليقنعهم بالنهايه كما تعرف الانتخابات
الامريكيه احيانا اذا وضعنا
والقضايا التي تطرح في الانتخابات احيانا
الشكل المظهر لغه الجسد كل هذه الاشياء
تؤثر وبالتالي هو حرم نفسه من اهم اطلاله
اذا اردت للناخبين وهو ان يكون امامهم
بشكل مرئي فهذه احد اخطاء ربما على الاقل
في هذه البدايه الغير موفقه حسب المرافق
انت يعني بالنسبه اليك هل توضحت لك
سياسات
ديسانتوس او برنامج ديسانس تحديدا في
مواضيع شائكه واساسيه مثل الحرب في
اوكرانيا العلاقه مع الصين الاقتصاد وسوى
ذلك هل هنالك برنامج واضح لديسانس يمكن
الركن اليه
لا اولا ديسنتوس يفتقد الى الخبره في
السياسه الخارجيه ومن هنا قبل اسابيع من
اعلان هذا الترشح الرسمي ذهب في رحله خارج
البلاد الى اليابان والى اسرائيل والى
غيرها وبالتالي اريد ان يقول بان هو يفهم
هذه المشاكل المعقده لكن الانتقادات طبعا
له انه هو حاكم ولايه بالنهايه لديه خبره
تنفيذيه دون ادنى شكل لديه بعض النجاحات
التي تسجل في ولايه فلوريدا لكن حتى في
ولايه فلوريدا لا يمكن ان تنقل هذه
النجاحات او هذه التطبيقات حتى الى ولايه
اخرى فما بالك اذا تحدثنا عن السياسه
الخارجيه وتحدثنا عن حرب اوكرانيا وغيرها
كانت له بعض التصريحات المثيره للجدل
بالنسبه لموقفه بالنسبه لروسيا الذي كان
نوعا ما متعاطف معها الى اخره لكن حتى
بالنسبه للاقتصاد طبعا في بدايه ازمه
كورونا ابقى على ولايه فلوريدا مفتوحه لكن
ايضا هو جذب بعض ربما رجال الاعمال الكبرى
للعمل في فلوريداكن ايضا هناك انتقادات هو
يصور نفسه كما ذكرت قبل قليل بانه هو
محافظ تقليدي يمثل ما كنا نعرفه عن الحزب
الجمهوري وهم محافظين اجتماعيا
ولديهم ايضا مواقف بالنسبه للاقتصاد
الانفاق يعني لا يريدون الحكومات كبيره لا
يريدون انفاق على مشاريع الديمقراطيين
يقومون فيها طوال الوقت لكن هل اهم اهم
مشكله هو يوجيه هل سيستطيع ان يطيح بالرجل
الاول الذي يتربى على قمه الهرم في الحزب
الجمهوري وهو الرئيس ترامب حتى الان هو
ناديه البعض يقول انه لدى البعض يقول ان
لدى ديسانتوس ورقه رابحه وهي زوجته وان
لها دور محوري سواء في جامعه تبرعات
لحملته الانتخابيه وكذلك في حشد الاصوات
له هل يعني دور زوج زوجه ديسانتوس في
امكانيه وصوله الى البيت الابيض ماذا يمكن
ان نقول هنا
اعتقد بانه ورقه الرابحه هي عمره
كما تعرف الرئيس بايدن في الثمانينات واهم
ما يقلق الناخب الامريكي هو تقدم الرئيس
بايدن بالعمر والشيخوخه التي نراها من
خلال كل ربما المواقف التي يتعرض لها
وايضا عمر الرئيس ترامب بانه بنهايه
السبعينات زوجات الرئيس او المرشحين يمكن
ان تلعب دورا كما راينا بالنسبه الاوباما
كانت تتمتع بشعبيه احيانا اكثر من زوجها
وكذلك لكن وحتى ملان يا ترامب لكن الدور
يبقى محدودا يعني جمع الاموال تتم من
ممولين يعتقدون بان هذا المرشح يمكن ان
يصل الى البيت الابيض بسياسات وبدعم من
اللوبي وغيره لكن اكيد يعني ان يكون له
هذه الاسره الجميله سواء كانت زوجها
واطفال صغار ويمثل الجناح التقليدي في
الحزب الجمهوري انه رجل اسره وبانه يحارب
كل القضاء ما يسمى بالكلشر التي يقودها
كما ذكرت ضد الكثير من الامور مثل الاجهاض
وغيرها وتدريس الجنس للاطفال والتحولات
والى اخره بالنسبه للعمليات والاخير هي
ممكن لكن بشكل عام اعتقد بان لديه مشوار
طويل حتى يقنع الجمهوريين اولا لنذكر بان
هناك انتخابات اوليه عليه ان يفوز بها قبل
ان يواجه على كل دائما يعني
كل هذه المتابعه من واشنط
ن
اعلنت الاحزاب المواليه للاكراد في تركيا
دعما مرشح الرئاسه المعارض كمالك في جوله
الاعاده في الانتخابات الرئاسيه دون
تسميته
وقالونا من حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
وحلفائهم من حزب اليسار الاخضر انهم يسعون
الى التغيير في جوله الاعاده ولا يقبلون
ببقايا اردوغان مشيرين الى انهم سيصوتون
لصالح انهاء نظام الرجل الواحد
دانه وزاره الخارجيه الفرنسيه اختبار
ايراني صاروخ باليستي بعيد المدى معتبره
انه انتهاك لقرارات مجلس الامن ومدعاه
للقلق في ضوء التوسع المتواصل للبرنامج
النووي الايراني ياتي هذا بعد اعلان
الجانب الايراني اجراء تجارب على اطلاق
صاروخ باليستي بنجاح
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
اعداد المهاجرين في بريطانيا تتجاوز رقما
قياسيا
ب 600 الف شخص العام الماضي
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشره الخامسه من
العربيه وصف رئيس الوزراء البريطاني اعداد
المهاجرين الى المملكه المتحده بانها
مرتفعه جدا حيث اظهرت بيانات رسميه اليوم
ان صافي عدد المهاجرين بلغ اكثر من 600
الف شخص في العام الماضي وهو رقم قياسي
ووفقا لمكتب الاحصاء الوطني فقد انتقل من
مجموعه واحد فاصل اثنين مليون شخص الى
المملكه المتحده في عام 2022
بينما غادرها نحو
وتعهد سوناك بخفض الارقام في حين توقع
وزير الهجره البريطانيه انخفاض صافي
الهجره في بريطانيا الى مستويات ما قبل
تفشي كورونا على المدى المتوسط بعد
ارتفاعها الى مستويات قياسيه في العام 20
الى لندن لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم اليكم هناك مراسل العربيه
مصطفى زاهر مصطفى اهلا وسهلا بك سوناك
تعهد بخفض هذا الرقم ولكن كيف وباي طريقه
هل من معلومات
حقيقه هذه ارقام
تقلق هؤلاء الذين كانوا يدعمون الانفصال
من الاتحاد الاوروبي لاستعاده السيطره على
حدود البلاد وبالتالي
ارقام مخيفه وايضا تزيد من الضغط على
الحكومه التي تقول بانها ملتزمه بان يتم
السيطره على اعداد المهاجرين الوافدين الى
المملكه المتحده مثل ما ذكرت بان هذا
الارتفاع كان زاد ب 20% عن السنه الماضيه
وهو رقم قياسي للمره الثانيه على التوالي
في اشاره الى ان سياسه الحكومه للتعاطي مع
الهجره يعني كان السياسه خاطئه لم تتعامل
بالشكل المطلوب وان بدات باتخاذ اجراءات
في محاوله لاعاده هذه الاعداد الى ما كانت
عليه قبل جائحه كورونا وبالتحديد كما تعهد
كما كان هناك تعهد في في قبل الانتخابات
عام 2019 بان تكون هذه الاعداد في حدود
245 الف مهاجر بالطبع نحن بعيدون كل البعد
عن هذه عن هذه الارقام التي كانت تسعى
اليها يعني شريحه معينه تدعم ما تقول
الحكومه الان بانها يعني اتخذت بعض
الاجراءات مثلا قبل يومين تم الاعلان عن
منع الطلاب البكالوريوس من احضار افراد
عائلاتهم هذا جزء بسيط من الصوره
المعقده للسيطره على الهجره ولكن الحكومه
تقول بانها تراجع كل ما يتعلق بالهجره
لوضع سياسه
تتماشى مع متطلبات البلد ولكن يجب التذكير
بان الاعداد الغفير التي تم نشرها هي بسبب
يعني عوامل استثنائيه بالنظر مثلا الى
الحرب في اوكرانيا كان هناك ما لا يقل الف
لاجئ من اوكرانيا بالاضافه الى اعداد ما
يقارب من 150 الف مواطن من هونغ كونغ يعني
اتى الى هذا البلد بسبب القرار الصيني
بسبب القرار الصيني بفرض قانون شامل على
هذه المنطقه بالرغم من كانت هناك وعود بان
بان تلتزم الصين مصطفى مصطفى
لو حاولت الحكومه البريطانيه حكومه
ريشيسوناك البدء بعمليات ترحيل لبعض او
لجول هؤلاء الم يزيد ذلك من يعني الوضع
السياسي ويعقد الوضع السياسي اكثر
لسوناك اكثر مما هو معقد الان
حقيقه هناك معضله كبيره وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بهؤلاء الذين ياتون من من فرنسا عبر قوارب
يعني مميته يعني بالنسبه مثلا العام
الماضي كان هناك ما يقارب من 45 الف مهاجر
غير شرعي وصلوا الى شواطئ البريطانيه فقط
هذا هذا العام خمسه الاف وهناك ايضا يعني
محاكم تنظر في هذه السياسه هناك عدد من
هؤلاء الذين يقولون بان يجب ان ان توفر
الحكومه لهم يعني حق اللجوء في هذا البلد
وبالتالي امام الحكومه معضله كبيره في
محاوله السيطره على هذه على الهجره ولكن
الكل ان يتساءل ما ان كان يعني محقا ان
تخرج بريطانيا الاتحاد الاوروبي خصوصا هو
ان العداد الغفيره التي وصلت العام الماضي
هم من خارج دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ميلاندا
مراسل العربيه مصطفى زاهر شكرا جزيلا لك
مصطفى على كل هذه المتابعه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه انه في ضوء
ما تم بحثه بين ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان ورئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن
تشودو على هامش قمه منتدى التعاون
الاقتصادي لاسيا والمحيط الهادئ في بانكوك
في نوفمبر الماضي فقط فقرر اعاده مستوى
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع كندا الى وضعها
السابق واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه في بيان
لها استئناف العلاقات مع كندا على اساس
الاحترام المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه
هذا وعنه الخارجيه الكنديه تعيين جونفيليب
سفيرا جديدا لدى المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الى رياض لمزيد من المتابعه حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الي من هناك مراسل العربيه
عبد الرحمن عبد الرحمن اهلا وسهلا بك لو
تعطينا لمحه عن المسار والاسباب التي دفعت
باتجاه عوده العلاقات بين الرياض بين كندا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه عبد الرحمن
اهلا طالب بيان وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه
اجاب على هذه الاسئله التي صدر يوم امس
وزاره الخارجيه السعوديه اكدت بان هناك
اجتماعا دار بين ولي العهد السعودي ورئيس
وزراء كندا في العاصمه تايلانديه بانكوك
في نوفمبر الماضي على هامش اجتماع منتدى
التعاون الاقتصادي لدول اسيا والمحيط
الهادئ هذا الاجتماع اكد على عده نقاط وهو
رغبه البلدين لعوده العلاقات التي شهدت
قطيعه طالب منذ قرابه الخمس سنوات في
اغسطس من عام 2018 قررت السعوديه قطع
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ايضا هناك مصدر
لوكاله رويترز اكد بان
سيتم رفع الاجراءات العقابيه التجاريه
التي اتخذتها السعوديه ضد كندا متوقع الان
بعد تعيين كندا لسفيرها في الرياض عبر
تغري كانت يوم امس في تقريبا الساعه
الثامنه مساء بتوقيت الرياض متوقع ايضا
يتم تعيين سفير السعودي قريبا وفي كندا
طبعا واتخاذ الاجراءات الدبلوماسيه لعوده
ايضا البعثه الدبلوماسيه وايضا فتح ابواب
السفاره السعوديه في كندا خلال الايام
القليله عبد الرحمن ستعود العلاقات الى
سابق عهدها بنفس الحراره وانعكاس ذلك على
العلاقات الاقتصاديه بين البلدين باختصار
بكل تاكيد طالب عندما نشاهد التبادلات
التجاريه بين
الرياض وكندا هناك ارقام مثيره للانتباه
طالب هناك اكثر يعني من تقريبا
12.3 مليار ريال سعودي كان حجم التبادل
التجاري بين السعوديه وكندا في عام 2015
ايضا حقق الميزان التجاري بين السعوديه
وكندا فائض ليقدر بحوالي 314 مليون ريال
سعودي ايضا الصادرات السعوديه الى كندا
تمثلت في منتجات تتعلق بالنفط الخام
والزيوت البتروليه ايضا هناك سياح كنديين
سنراهم يعودون بشكل كبير الطيران
المباشر بين كندا والسعوديه توقف خلال
السنوات الخمس الماضيه سنشاهد ايضا رحلات
مباشره بينك الرياض ومنتريال وجده ايضا
وفانكوفر ايضا
طالب هناك ارقام مهمه جدا اكثر من 12 الف
سعودي كانوا موجودين في كندا المبتعثين
يشكلون 7000
مبتعد مبتعثه من الاثني عشره الف سعودي
هناك في مونتريال لوحدها اكثر من 300 طبيب
سعودي كانوا يعملون في المستشفيات كل هذه
الارقام ستعود الى سابق عهدها بين
السعوديه وكندا من الرياض مراسل العربي
عبد الرحمن العصيمي شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
الرحمن على كل هذه المعلومات
عثرت الحمايه المدنيه الجزائريه بولايه
قالمه الشرقي البلاد على جثه طفله بسبب
الفيضانات في الولايه هذا وشهدت ولايات
جزائريه فيضانات خلال اليومين الماضيين
تسببت في حدوث خسائر ماديه وغرفا للطرقات
[موسيقى]
قولوا العلماء الذين يدرسون قشره سطح
المريخ ان ابحاثهم الاخيره ستساعد اي مهمه
ماهوله مستقبليه الى الكوكب الاحمر
وقد عكف فريق العلماء في ناسا على تحليل
صوت زلزال قدرت قوته باربع فاصل ست درجات
على المريخ وهو اكبر زلزال سجلته بعثته
ناسا لتحديد هيكل القشره بما في ذلك
سمكتها وكثفتها
[موسيقى]
العظيم في هذا الزلزال هو انه كان قويا
لدرجه ان موجات السطح كانت قادره على ان
تجوب الكوكب باكمله عده مرات الموجات تدور
بشكل اساسي ثلاث مرات على الاقل والشيء
رائع في هذه الملاحظه هو انه يمكننا الان
ان نبدا بقياس السرعه التي تنتقل بها هذه
الموجات السطحيه على طول الكوكب وبناء على
هذه السرعه يمكننا في الواقع استخراج
المعلومات حول الطبقات الداخليه للمريخ
[موسيقى]
نشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
مزيد من الاخبار على مواقعنا على شبكات
التواصل الاجتماعي وعلى موقع العربيه على
الانترنت العربيه
والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات